intérêt pour participer au dépistage
organisé c'est vraiment la double
lecture de votre mammographie par deux
radios différents libérez la parole face
au cancer du sein une journée de
sensibilisation était organisée ce
mercredi 4 octobre au Centre Social
l'Agora d'Élancourt échange sur la
prévention ou l'accompagnement une
nécessité de dialogue façades
3 millions de femmes entre 50 et 74 ans
n'ont jamais participé à un dépistage
contre cette maladie on a beaucoup de
femmes qui ont une méconnaissance des
modalités de participation des pistaches
du cancer du sein on a beaucoup de
femmes aussi qui ne pensent pas à
prendre le temps de s'occuper d'elle si
un cancer est détecté précocement cela
va permettre à 99 femmes sur 100 de
pouvoir survivre dans les cinq ans des
150e anniversaire chacune reçoit à son
domicile un courrier l'invitant à
prendre rendez-vous pour un examen
auprès d'un radiologue en amont
l'auto-examen mammaire régulier et
recommandé à partir de 25 ans avec des
spécifique un volume de 5 qui peut
augmenter ou alors qui change de forme
eu un mamelon qui va se rétracter une
induration ou alors tout simplement un
une rougeur sur le sein une peau
d'orange et ensuite de passer au toucher
c'est à dire de pouvoir tout simplement
toucher ses seins aussi largement
possible pour que tout simplement on
puisse sentir des choses qui ne seraient
pas habituelles durant ce mois de
prévention octobre rose de nombreux
événements seront proposés à Élancourt
prochain rendez-vous ce weekend avec des
activités familiales pour soutenir la
lutte contre le cancer le plus fréquent
chez la femme